la virginie est un des états où il ya le
plus de mises à mort 1387 condamné y ont
subi la peine capitale
gaoua on pouvait sentir la chair brûlée
jerry games est responsable d exécution
à la prison de richmond
de 1982 à 1999 il travaille dans le
couloir de la mort qui a ses règles ses
rituels et ce non dit je leur rase la
tête et les jambes que le courant passe
mieux l'électricité passe à travers le
casque alors il fallait raser les
cheveux je plaçais la main sur leur tête
et je criais pour à haute voix ou un
silence
jerry games n'a jamais pensé qu'il
travaillerait dans une prison jeune il
songe au métier de policier mais rêve
surtout aux sports quand j'étais enfant
je voulais devenir un joueur de football
une blessure met fin à ses ambitions
il va de petits boulots en petits
boulots jusqu'à la prison de richmond où
un emploi lui est offert mais nego
intérêts les portes se ferment que la
campagne
c'est un son qu'on n'oublie jamais
il vient de se bâtir une réputation de
dur à cuire à l'intérieur des murs son
patron lui propose de devenir bourreau
après réflexion il accepte
il se souvient encore de la première
fois j'étais nerveux nécesaire frères
swan c'était notre première exécution en
vingt ans il y avait beaucoup de gens y
en avait partout le 10 août 1982 à une
heure le matin un condamné pour meurtre
fringues coppola donne le feu vert donné
on lui a demandé s'il souhaitait faire
une dernière déclaration
ils en avaient déposé dit allons-y il
active
trois mille volts sur la chaise
électrique en date krumm bataille du
rail
je ne pense à rien c'est juste la
machine qui marche
elle fait son boulot dans les arts
c
jerry games en dur moins bien les
exécutions par injection létale liquide
qu'il injecte donne l'impression d'
utile d'être trop près du condamné
le gars chanter amazing grace les hommes
y compris de dalian il a presque eu le
temps de terminer la chanson avant que
l'injection arrive à tuer la jeune garde
au 06 62 un total de 62
tout commence aux tiger-cats je devais
me convaincre que les gars étaient
coupables sans l'ombre d'un doute il est
admis guillot t il le fallait pour
satisfaire ma conscience
un jour un des condamnés à mort de gerry
games est innocente et ils commencent
alors à douter avec des tirages de gerry
le juge et juin condamne le prisonnier
moi j'exécute la sentence s'il est
innocent c'est leur erreur et c'est moi
qui le tue je crois que dieu me disais
il ya des personnes innocentes
c'est le temps d'arriver à il cachera
durant vingt ans à sa femme et à ses
enfants son métier de bourron au moment
où il est prêt à quitter son travail en
prison il sera condamné à 50 pénitencier
pour une fraude dit il qu'il n'a pas
commises
il refusera de témoigner à son procès
pour éviter de dévoiler son travail et
c'est la harpe ligue 1 il offrait de
réduire ma peine à six mois sans
détention si je plaide coupable
pas question je sais que je n'étais pas
coupable à sa sortie de prison il ne
croit plus au système et dénonce la
peine de mort publiquement in hope
ils disent que ce n'est pas de la
vengeance sans nec nous allons tous
mourir
nous sommes tous condamnés à mort c'est
inévitable à ce que ma mère
aujourd'hui john riggins dessine donne
des conférences et chante à l'église
oui ça je l' ai toujours été au nom d'un
bar